[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24 y
me acompaña en el estudio más Romero
sala mar bienvenida buena mañana de
martes y nosotros nos vamos a Europa en
esta sección de salud del día de hoy
porque ese continente está atravesando
uno de los peores brotes de gripear más
grandes de la última décadamar Buenos
días
que se acumulan en los casos hoy vamos a
recoger un poco Cómo Está avanzando esta
situación porque son cifras a las que no
estábamos acostumbrados a pesar de que
haya pequeños brotes de gripe aviar
entre las aves de una forma bastante
regular estamos hablando concretamente
de 2.500 casi 2.500 brotes desde que ha
empezado la epidemia eso ha comportado
Además del sacrificio de 47,7 millones
de aves como medidas para evitar que se
siga propagando importante decir estos
brotes es en aves no en persona la
verdad explicaremos mejor eso una de las
cosas Además más extrañas Es que
normalmente estos brotes se
intensificaban Ah pues a cuando entraba
el hemisferio norte en el otoño y en el
invierno no los meses que ahora
transitando pero en este caso se ha
venido prolongando desde los meses de
verano por ejemplo de junio a septiembre
en plena época estival en el hemisferio
norte los brotes de naves domésticas
fueron cinco veces más que en el mismo
periodo de el año anterior así que bueno
vemos que las cifras están haciendo
verdaderamente altas Mark le preguntó si
es un riesgo real para los humanos este
virus de la gripe aviar Sí esa es la
gran pregunta que tenemos todos y la
verdad es que no no en general los
contagios a personas son muy frecuentes
ahora también revisaremos las cifras no
es un virus que se transmita bien entre
personas no en general quién se
contagian son personas que tienen que
tener una exposición muy prolongada por
ejemplo trabajadores
exactamente el problema es que
últimamente como estamos viendo los
brotes son cada vez más comunes por lo
tanto cada vez hay más personas que
pueden estar expuestas y también que el
contagio de algunas de las cepas de
estos virus de la gripe aviar pueden
tener tasas de mortalidad verdaderamente
altas no por ejemplo el h5n1 tiene una
tasa de mortalidad 60% es decir es poco
probable que te contagies pero si uno se
contagia puede estar en problemas además
pues obviamente existe la preocupación
también de que el virus se termine
mutando para hacerse más transmisible
entre las personas y si algo hemos
aprendido de la pandemia es que más
contagios más mutaciones verdad Pero
bueno no es la primera vez que que
sucede esto de las mutaciones Aunque por
ahora no ha sido para que se haga más
transmisible entre los humanos este
virus se descubrió en 1996 en China y en
el año siguiente hubo 18 infectados en
Hong Kong 6 de ellos terminaron
falleciendo entre 2003-2005 se expandió
a Europa provocando también pequeñas
crisis puntuales en ese momento y luego
fue en 2014-2016 que fue mutando hasta
dos variantes distintas de este virus
que se hicieron predominantes dejaron 77
infecciones en humanos en todo el mundo
sin embargo ahora lo que se ha
descubierto es eso que entonces este
brote que está ocasionando es en 2022
vuelve a ser de una nueva versión del h5
n1 y hoy en día tenemos tres infecciones
una se ha registrado en España otra en
Reino Unido y otra en Estados Unidos
hablaba de la pandemia Y por supuesto
que vamos a volver a hablar de las
vacunas a contra el 19 porque
recientemente me ha habido un revuelo de
raíz de unas declaraciones de pfizer y
vaya usted qué está pasando por qué
tanta polémica no podemos abandonar la
pandemia aunque se acabe exactamente y
aún así yo creo que la Seguiremos
recordando durante mucho tiempo
exactamente Sí bueno es un debate que
empezó de hecho en Europa hace unas
semanas y que ahora está llegando a
estas orillas del Atlántico el contexto
es que en una comparecencia de una
ejecutiva de faither en el parlamento
europeo dijo que se había distribuido la
vacuna de pfizer sin que se hubiera
demostrado previamente que evitaba la
transmisión esto causó mucho revuelo
hubo muchos titulares diciendo como se
comercializó la vacuna sin que se
mostrara o sin que se dijera si era
eficaz no sin que para la transmisión y
a mí me parece una especie de caso de
amnesia colectiva un poco extraña que
además de eso está llegando ahora este
es por ejemplo entre tantos es un ex
senador colombiano que criticaba al ex
gobierno al antiguo gobierno del ex
presidente Duque en Colombia que hubiera
comprado y hubiera administrado las
vacunas de pfizer sin tener esta Pues
esta evitar la transmisión a demostrada
no esa este está siendo como lo que
están poniendo sobre la mesa ahora como
contrastamos nosotros estas afirmaciones
bueno precisamente por esta especie de
amnesia colectiva que parece que no nos
acordemos de lo que estábamos hablando
hace un año fuimos a ver lo que
publicaba la agencia europea del
medicamento que no es muy distinto a lo
que publicó la fda o otras agencias
regulatorias de los medicamentos en esa
época y vemos por ejemplo esta revisión
no decía que había una eficacia
excelente en prevenir el covid
sintomático que era probable que
protegiera el covid grave ahora hemos
visto ampliamente que también lo ha
hecho pero sobre todo lo que es
importante es que dice que no sabes si
la vacuna protege contra la infección
asintomática o su impacto en la
transmisión viral lo dijimos muchas
veces en ese momento sabíamos que las
vacunas nos de enfermarnos gravemente
nos prevenían de entrar al hospital que
para las personas con más riesgo era muy
importante pero no sabíamos Qué nuevas
dinámicas epidemiológicas de transmisión
del virus iban a introducir hoy en día
de hecho podemos decir que no que no son
del todo eficaces en prevenir la
transmisión ya nos ha pasado mucho Que
pues nos estamos vacunados y nos hemos
contagiado Igualmente de Kobe 19 lo que
sí ha pasado es que al haber menos
personas enfermas ha ayudado a frenar un
poco esta transmisión pero no es el
papel de la vacuna los estudios que se
hicieron inicialmente para probar la
seguridad y la eficacia contra la
prevención de la enfermedad del covid-19
no estaban buscando responder si
prevenían la transmisión o no Así que en
verdad no estamos descubriendo Nada
nuevo no sabíamos que iba a pasar era un
momento de emergencia en el que lo que
importaba era que la gente no entrara en
los hospitales no entonces pues es un
poco falaz decir que no saber que
prevenía la transmisión es algo nuevo lo
sabíamos desde hace tiempo y además pues
sigue siendo totalmente segura y fue una
gran una gran decisión de todos los
implementar la vacunación claro yo desde
el principio de las informaciones
oficiales y sobre todo los meses decían
que pues esta vacuna no escriba de
impedir este contagio sino simplemente
que evitar que tuvieras un covid grave
que fueras al hospital no ser entubado y
que evitar menos muerte por eso
hablábamos de esa amnesiano que ahora
parece que con esta alarma de repente no
nos acordemos de lo que estábamos
diciendo hace un año y medio pero pues
esto no sabíamos desde el principio
Muchísimas gracias mar como siempre
mañana más salud